welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and with the
digital release of Avengers endgame
making its way across the multiverse we
have some extra details about the film
from the directors commentary throughout
this video I'll be breaking down the top
ten details that the Russo brothers
dropped about the film during their
discussion as well as giving my thoughts
on the reveals there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch Avengers endgame yeah I
don't know why I'm doing this I'm not
gonna bother with a spoiler warning
you've seen Avengers endgame anyway
without the way let's get into my
breakdown of the Avengers and game
commentary number one how Captain Marvel
found the ship okay so first up is a big
point of contention about the opening
half hour of the film most notably to do
with Captain Marvel miraculously she
seemed to appear out of nowhere to save
Tony Stark and nebula from death by
boredom and one of the big criticisms
lobbied at the film is how did she know
whereabouts they were well it turns out
that in an off-screen scene rocket told
her about homing beacon that she was
able to use and find an us get Tony home
in time to call cap Alya and go off to
live in the woods this definitely helps
to clear up one of the biggest potholes
in the film and whilst it would have
been nice to have seen a Sun screen I
guess we can kind of draw our own
conclusions over this ultimately I would
have loved for Tony to get himself out
of the situation similar to the cave
scene from Iron Man but I guess the
characters had to meet in some way so
this saw bridges the gap number two
Hulk's favorite ice cream next up comes
a huge Easter egg that no one seems to
have spotted at all till the director's
pointed it out this comes in the Hulk
introduction scene when we first see
what Bruce Banner has become and when
the group are sitting around the diner
table you will notice that Hulk is
eating some hunka hunka burning fudge
ice cream this of course is a massive
callback to infinity war and Bruce
discover that he'd had an ice cream
named after him and I have no idea why
Ben and Jerry's haven't made this and
the stark raving haze on that yet but
someone needs to snap their marketing
team out of existence right now come on
guys were won it anyway I love this
little Easter egg and it's such a subtle
nod to the white
universe that really lets you know why
kids still want to take selfies with the
big lean green machine number three
skinny stock okay so back to the opening
of the film and the directors revealed
that the Tony Stark's scene on earth in
which he bust down how he and the rest
of the Avengers are all failures was
heavily edited with CGI to make Tony
appear skinny and malnourished Joe Russo
revealed that the intent here was to
make you believe if momentarily that we
actually killed Tony Stark at the start
that film damn if only had some of that
stark Ravin haze on that
am i right this should make it bending
Jerry she should make it I was that was
a good one was anyway I'll move on
number four Hawkeye was originally in
infinity war next up is quite a big one
from the film in which the Russo
brothers revealed that the scene with
Hawkeye in his daughter was actually in
infinity war and was going to be one of
the last shots of the film however the
two said that they cut this scene
because they thought it was too
disorientating for audiences to go to
two characters that hadn't featured in
the film and thus they saved it for the
start of this I do agree with this as
the pacing of the scene is a little slow
and to end on it would have probably
diminished the ending so I do think it
was right to save it for this then it
kind of builds on the ronan arc in the
film and either way it's a nice little
bit of information that reminds us just
how closely intertwined these two films
are when scenes can be swapped back and
forth from them number five how Thanos
got to the present another big plot hole
that people have question is how did Dan
Oz managed to get from 2014 to 2023
during the commentary the Russos
revealed that on his ship he and ebony
more had managed to reverse engineer the
Pym particle and this is how they were
able to move through time as Rocket
hilariously says his doctor in the film
Tony is only a genius on earth and we
know that Thanos is cursed with
knowledge so that it makes sense he
would be able to do such a thing with
the technology on his ship and I'm glad
that this was finally confirmed by the
directors number six smart hulks first
appearance now cast your mind back to
infinity war once more and you might
remember that around the time of its
release there were several toys that
originally showed Hulk busting out of
the Hulkbuster armor but we never
actually got this in the film even in
the infinity war extras stephen mcfeely
who was a screenwriter on both infinity
war and endgame revealed the following
in the commentary for the latest
the whole arc of the story was banner
and Hulk were not getting along
Hulk wouldn't come out to help him and
at his hour of greatest need they'd make
some sort of compromise and smart Hulk
rips out the armor and beats the crap
out of Cole obsidian and destroys him it
was pretty clear that infinity war could
not handle this weird success and the
movie just needed to stay in its
succession of losses in the third act
which meant some hustling on the part of
the VFX are late in the game so we could
have actually gotten smart Hulk in
infinity war however I actually think
the delay and quick snap to him that
weekend endgame works a lot better and
though the action figure is amazing I'm
glad that they held off on this number 7
how Ironman removed the stones watching
tannaz snap his fingers only to turn the
corner round to see that the stones
weren't there is an awesome moment in
the film and definitely one of the most
satisfying points in the entire MCU
however many wondered how Tony actually
managed to get a hold of the stones and
we finally have answers in the
commentary we learned that Tony's suits
are actually able to talk to one another
and that Stark was able to use the
nanotechnology in his armor to strip the
stones from Thanos and then form them
himself this could be another reason why
Tony was the only one capable of saving
the universe and adds to why strange was
so desperate to save him at the end of
Infinity Ward number 8 Danis killed the
Avengers
Christopher Marcus the other
screenwriter on the film revealed that
after reverse engineering the Pym
particle that Thanos traveled through
time and killed a younger more
inexperienced version of the Avengers
and then traveled to 2023 and through
Captain America's severed head at them
when they approached him I've covered
this scene in more detail so definitely
check that video if you want to know
more but I can see why this was cut
their staff it would have made more
sense of throat Thor's head at him and
second yeah far too many beheadings for
a Disney movie number 9 Nebula doesn't
know exactly how Gamora died another big
point of contention around the film was
the fact that nebula didn't tell Black
Widow and Hawkeye that in order to get
the soulstone that one of them would
have to sacrifice their life McFeely
used the commentary to clear this plot
point up and stated that though nebula
knew of gomorrah's death she didn't know
how it happened and that it was in
relation to the soulstone hence why she
didn't really advise
then before going this makes a lot of
sense as nebula maybe an a-hole but
she's not and I'm quoting her here a
complete dick number 10 when Steve
arrived and finally you might have not
been able to see this bit because of the
tears in your eyes but at the end of the
movie when cap and Peggy finally danced
with one another the door of the house
is open because this is literally the
first thing that they do when he arrives
there it's a really nice little detail
that tops off the film and lets you know
that they finally have each other and
aren't wasting any time and that's the
10 amazing details we learn from the
director's commentary of Avengers
endgame let me know which one was your
favorite and if there's anything else in
the film that I missed out be sure to
leave it in the comment section below if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my video
on all of the deleted scenes included
with the digital release would you be
linked at the end I go over everything
and break down my thoughts on the cut
content so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books then you
can follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this I also just want to let you know
that we're currently giving away a free
copy of Avengers endgame on blu-ray to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the commentary in the
comment section below the world will be
chosen at random on August the 10th and
the blue row be shipped out from them to
ever get surprised it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace